the first time I ever made a delivery
was in the spring of 1953 and I was 6
months old
on my father's route I grew up doing
this thousand-man my name is Walter
Beckerman and I am a salsa man your
salsa man is the order-taker the bottle
fixer the driver to deliver the salesman
your everything rolled into one people
ask you what it is about the celsa
business that makes you want to continue
doing it
you hold that sells about and you hold
history your whole memories you hold an
object of beauty
that's 1871 it still works without these
bottles this business doesn't exist this
machine is a Barnett and Foster siphon
filling machine I think it was made in
London early 1900s
it's a six siphon wave filling machine
goes around through the carousel and
only one bottle goes in at a time so
it's a lot of work the reason this is a
better Seltzer is because there's
nothing else in this seltzer other than
New York City tap water which is triple
filtered through sand charcoal and paper
and co2 and fortunately as long as the
machine is fixed and I have a place to
fill I can't see any reason why this
business should be a nail in the coffin
situation where it's over it won't be
over to the last bowel cells is squirted
and I don't see that anytime soon